I don't usually do this but I I didn't
want to say this there's one guy in
tonight's crowd who caught my eye the
guy on the aisle in the fourth row right
there yes that gentleman right there
yeah he has been I want to just point
him out because don't get me wrong don't
get me wrong you've been a terrific
crowd so far but this guy has been
laughing and clapping and just having an
amazing time and he caught my eye he's
having such a good time and I just I
gotta talk to him sir what is your name
hey Conan my name is Greg Miller Greg
Miller okay cool well thanks for being
here Greg
and were you from from eastern
Pennsylvania okay Wow okay you came all
the way from eastern Pennsylvania huh
yeah and here's a little more about me
like I said my name is Greg Miller I'm
from Eastern PA with my wife Monique and
my son shrink he's 8 years old
I work as a claims adjuster at
Pennsylvania Life been there for seven
years life is good you know nothing too
exciting so the chance to come out to LA
to see a conan taping that was a big
deal
hold it hold it what the hell was that
just a short piece not prepared just in
case you noticed me in the crowd and had
any questions I was just making
conversation I didn't need a mini
documentary about you
sorry oh man do I feel stupid
take a look I knew that just taken over
show like that making it all about me
thrown in a little bio piece that Conan
didn't ask for it was risky but I made
my bed and now I have to lie in it we'll
just see what happens I'm sorry
how did you know to film an apology
video I was just thinking ahead I'm a
planner wait I'm sorry how does a random
audience member get to show pre-tape
pieces on my show anyway I feel bad man
I've wasted your time it's no no don't
now
it's fine don't don't worry no no man I
think I should go I soon be here yeah
come on back Greg Greg I'm sorry that's
not necessary Greg that's how you get
out of a Conan taping
[Music]
I see whose side you're on all right
you